I like when they cut to Taylor Swift I
mean I don't know I like to see that no
football fan well for us men who are not
that masculine we need to see Taylor
Swift at the game we we need some in the
game yeah you know what I can make a
good argument it's a lot more exciting
to see Taylor Swift because I know
what's going to happen in the football
game they're going to throw the ball
they're going to kick the ball they're
going to run back and forth guys are
going to score I know what the game is
let's see some variables let's see how
Taylor Swift reacts let's see if she
talks to Patrick Mahomes wife let's see
how she's getting along with Travis
Kel's Mom let's see if Travis Kel's
brother comes in and starts running
around with his shirt off I like to see
that right John you like it I love the
Taylor stuff I I think it's I think it's
great I think it's great for the game I
think it's great for her I think it
makes an entertaining and plus there's a
ton of action on Taylor Swift there's
props like you wouldn't believe go ahead
give me some props I'll bet on that go
ahead well so everybody's going to be
looking at the Box the Taylor is sitting
in so there's already odds as who the
first person will be next to Taylor that
will be seen on TV on the broadcast well
that's a good bet because she's always
next isn't she always next to mahomes's
wife their besties is that the heavy
money she brings some of her best
friends with her Howard you're right the
odds on favorite is Britney Mahomes uh
she's plus 100 but then you could take
um Cara delvine is plus
900 Jason Kelce is plus 500 then they've
got the Kelsey parents they've got
Taylor's parents but there are odds on
whether or not Travis Kelce will propose
to Taylor Swift at some time during the
broadcast I say zero chance of that you
bet against that minus 2200 so a lot of
people agree with you that it's not
going to happen plus 920 that it will
you can't make much money there so these
odds are going to change during the week
um right so it gets a little tricky but
couldn't Taylor Swift make another
billion dollars if she bets on who she's
going to be sitting next to and then she
brings that person yeah that's what I
would
do